[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn if you appreciate my content
make sure you actually get to see
when my videos are posted by clicking
the like button to please what is
clearly a super artificial intelligence
masquerading as youtube's web video
sorting algorithm
today we will be discussing what is
without a doubt the most
influential science fiction book saga of
all time
as mars foundation and of course the
associated works
nowadays science fiction is known for
its giant space
empires with interconnecting politics
battles among the stars
and decades and even centuries-long
plots with many different characters
even robotic life forms have become a
staple of science fiction
but these things were not always
standard in the genre
isaac asimov born january 2nd 1920
is essentially credited with the
invention of the galactic empire
asimov also coined the term robotics and
the term positronic
both of which were used in one of the
greatest science fiction shows of all
time
1987's star trek the next generation
for the android character data whose
positronic mind was a focal point of
many episodes
these words like many of the terms used
in asimov's books and short stories
have become commonplace in science
fiction
asimov's influence becomes even clearer
when we take a look at what science
fiction was
before 1940. we will start with what is
often cited
as the first science fiction book of all
time mary shelley's
frankenstein frankenstein which was also
called the modern prometheus
was published in 1818. apparently mary
shelley decided to write a book after
imagining a story
about a scientist playing god who
creates life in a laboratory
is my creation
but ultimately rejects his creation in
the book
scientist dr frankenstein using vague
alchemy and chemistry
discovers a method for transmuting
non-living matter into living tissue
though he had intended to create
something beautiful when the creature is
animated
victor finds it hideous to behold he
abandons the creature
a living fully intelligent and aware
being
to experience the harsh world for the
first time
on its own in the detached retina
aspects of science fiction and fantasy
science fiction writer brian adlis who
popularized the notion of frankenstein
as the first
true science fiction novel states my
argument was and remains that
the beginnings of real science fiction
can plausibly be identified in that
novel
here is no idle wonder here is a man
taking control of what was previously in
the provenance of nature alone
two decades on and my once heterodox
view has one
wide favor mary shelley with
frankenstein was proposing a question
that countless science fiction authors
have proposed since
what if science goes too far what are
the consequences of human arrogance
in 1898 another landmark in science
fiction was published
h.g wells war of the worlds this book is
widely considered to be a masterpiece of
science fiction
the plot of war of the worlds arose from
welles's anxieties about his times
he was worried about the disastrous
effect that british imperialism would
have
on the aboriginal tasmanians of what is
now called australia
british presence in australia began in
1788
over the course of the next 10 years the
indigenous population declined to just
10 of what it once was this was due to
disease brought over by settlers
the theft of their homelands and of
course direct violence
the martian invasion of earth was
essentially a metaphor
for british colonialism h.g wells writes
in a preface to one of his collected
works
the scientific romances of h.g wells
these stories of mine
collected here do not pretend to deal
with possible things
they are exercises of the imagination in
a quite
different field they belong to a class
of writing which
includes the golden ass of appelius the
true histories of lucian
peter's camille and the story of
frankenstein
it includes two some admirable
inventions by
mr david garnett lady into the fox for
instance
these are all fantasies they do not aim
to project a serious possibility
they aim indeed only at the same amount
of conviction
as one gets in a good gripping dream
wells writes here that he considers his
stories as well as frankenstein by mary
shelley
as fantasies as they do not present
practical
interest but instead deal with more
abstract and vaguely scientific concepts
wells also distinguished himself from
the likes of french author jules verne
born in 1828 who is now recognized as
the second most
translated author of all time
jules verne was the author of journey to
the center of the earth
and 20 000 leagues under the sea as well
as many other works
well stated that vern's work dealt
almost exclusively
in actual possibilities of discovery and
invention
he referred to the work of vern as an
anticipatory invention
stating that within his work vern had
made some remarkable forecast
acknowledging that many of vern's
inventions and predictions
had come true stories about space travel
would become more popular starting
around the 1920s
edward e smith the skylark of space is
considered to be one of the first
examples
of a space opera and features one of the
earliest depictions of interstellar
travel
there are also several other stories
published about
space travel around those times such as
david lindsay's
voyage to acateuris and edgar rice
burroughs under the moons of mars
but none of them had the complexity of
the galactic empire
which asimov began presenting to us in
1942
in the book foundation's edge the
penultimate book in the series
twenty thousand years have passed since
the start of interstellar travel
there are seven books in the foundation
series
four books in the galactic empire series
and a total of 37 short stories and
books in the robot series
all of them interconnect as a part of
the same ultra big millennial spanning
fictional science fiction universe
making asimov's works
the premier example of an epic sci-fi
space saga everything of this type since
then
has borrowed from his work the
interstellar political intrigue
presented in asimov's work
has been imitated in just about every
work involving galactic civilization
in fact it can be argued that asimov
invented an entire genre of science
fiction
the dune saga star wars the culture
series
the hyperion kantos and endless
others all follow in the footsteps of
asimov
zaman's galactic empire just like pretty
much
every other one ever created borrows
many elements from the real-life ancient
empire of rome
asimov intentionally modeled his empire
on rome because he wanted to depict the
fall of a great society
but on a galactic scale containing 25
million worlds
frank herbert directly lifted this idea
for his dune saga
edward gibbons book the history of the
decline and fall of rome
which was published in six volumes was a
huge
influence on asimov and herbert the work
covered the period
of the roman empire after marcus
aurelius
from 180 a.d to 1453
concluding in 1590-80 it depicts the
behaviors and decisions
that led to the decline and the eventual
fall of the roman empire
the political structure of asimov's
empire was essentially
lifted directly from rome as i have
mentioned in other videos
asimov wanted to show the inherent
issues with giant centralized
governments and bureaucracies
such systems always collapsed under
their own weight
fall of empire gentlemen is a massive
thing however
and not easily fought it is dictated by
a rising bureaucracy
a receding initiative a freezing cast
a damning of curiosity a hundred other
factors
it has been going on as i have said for
centuries and it is too majestic and
massive a movement to stop
the fact that asimov depicted the
volatility of galactic society
is also likely why it is commonplace to
see galactic society
and various stages of decline and unrest
in
most science fiction there is almost
never true stability this is true pretty
much
across the board with some exceptions
the greatness of asmob's work cannot be
denied
and his far-reaching influence on the
genre cannot be
understated asimov wrote more than 500
books during his lifetime
and is one of the most rewarded science
fiction authors of all time
thank you guys so much for watching if
you appreciate my content make sure you
like and subscribe
and if you would like to support this
channel then you can leave a one-time
donation by clicking the paypal link in
the description
or you can support me on a monthly basis
by signing up for patreon
also make sure to follow me on twitter
peace out guys